at the beginning of season nine we
received a bit of information that
cleared up some of the speculation and
confusion following the death of fey lau
at the end of season four
one such piece was the manhunt summary
that confirmed faye was indeed killed by
the division
however we were also able to get our
hands on the personal journal of the
late president ellis and what he
discusses opens us up to a number of
insights from behind enemy lines and
concerns far greater than what we've
been considering up until now
[Music]
[Music]
as a reference point i'm going to read
through the information we gathered
called alice's memoirs
following this i'm going to break down
and discuss what this means but if
you're quite familiar with these please
feel free to skip forward to the time
shown on screen
this whole organization is a complete
[ __ ] show i never should have agreed to
work with these idiots they think i'm
their patsy their chicken hawk
that i'm just gonna roll over and do
whatever they want i'm the goddamn
president of the united states of
america the greatest country in the
whole damn world
and some rich [ __ ] obsessed with
proving her dead daddy wrong is not
going to take me down
that woman is trying to build an empire
on the ashes
good luck with that she told me there's
only two things standing in her way her
brother and the button whatever that
means
well andrew congratulations you're a
[ __ ] genius
you became the leader of the free world
just in time to install a global elite
militia as warden and you have no one to
blame but yourself
the government was not perfect but it
wasn't a fascist nightmare and now
thanks to your stupid [ __ ] deal with
the literal she-devil you've got two
options
do what she says push the button and
blow up the world
all for once grow a [ __ ] pair and
stand up to the people trying to control
you
they can't activate the protocol without
your permission there are fail-safes
against it if you make one good decision
in your whole [ __ ] miserable life
make this one
and now i'm journaling in third person
this is not a good sign
andrew get your [ __ ] together stop
acting so [ __ ] crazy
do not allow natalia sokolova to bully
you into pushing the button
do what you do best andrew
lie
pretend that you'll do it
tell her that you'll do it
play the harbinger of death so that you
can [ __ ] her over and be the hero
i can do this i can beat her at her own
game and when people find out what i've
gone through when they read my memoirs
in 20 years they will know the real hero
of the story the person who saved them
from the brink of annihilation in the
face of danger was president andrew
ellis
i will be the hero of the story
mark my words i'll get this country back
on track and out of this god forsaken
pandemic
as long as i'm alive america will be
safe from natalia sokolova and that
snake mcmanus
firstly these memoirs tell us that alice
was growing disillusioned with natalya
in the black tusk from quite early on
he understood the key role he would play
to help further their plans
but ultimately was unwilling to do what
they wanted
however for the time being he would
continue to play along pretending to be
another loyal and easily manipulated
porn until his moment to shine finally
came along then he would take his stance
refused to cooperate and ultimately put
a stop to their plans despite what could
happen to him
in his own words president andrew ellis
would become the hero of this event in
the history of the united states of
america
and then bloody fae comes along and guns
them down
it's a nice story but i by no means
think ellis was strong enough to
withstand what natalya and the black
tusk could have done to him and the
lengths they would have gone to in order
to get what they wanted from him
it's clear that even in the end he's
still somewhat painted himself in a
slightly better light for the history
books or so i guess
yet realistically and however he will be
remembered in the future what faye did
still without question needed to be done
however what did he mean in regards to
natalya proving her dead daddy wrong and
what does there's only two things
standing in her way her brother and the
button really mean
i'll get to the button soon but first
let's speculate about this potential
family situation
as a recap
russian businessman alexei sokolov was
the founder and ceo of the hugely
successful international military
equipment manufacturer circle of concern
alexi had a daughter from a previous
relationship that had earlier separated
for unknown reasons
he later married an american woman and
eventually they had his first and only
son felix
as a family they decided to relocate to
his wife's country of birth the united
states
but left behind his daughter to keep the
family business ticking along
her name was natalia sokolova
alexi was very hard on felix as he had
high hopes and numerous expectations
that he was constantly forcing upon his
son
after he graduated from school felix was
told by his father that he must enlist
with the navy
there while on deployment his father
died under suspicious circumstances
and after a lengthy court battle felix's
mother was eventually convicted of
alexi's murder
when felix's tour was over he began
studying medicine at john hopkins
university and this is when natalia
reached out to him
she immediately took over funding for
his studies and attempted to reunite
with the brother that she barely knew
also during felix's time at university
he was approached and recruited by the
strategic homeland division
however not long after following this he
would also be recruited by the black
tusk a new private military company
founded by his sister
there felix will be placed under
feylau's care preparing for a future
operation
[Music]
you asking the other candidates this
much about their families only when it's
relevant so what else do you want to
know how close are you with your sister
not as close as i'd like
it's hard she grew up in russia i didn't
really get to know her until after our
father died that was what six or seven
years ago
six
what does it matter nothing just that's
around the same time she started black
tusk
so oh
nothing i'm just thinking out loud
it's interesting that your father dies
she reconnects or connects with you
she inherits the company and builds this
pmc it just seems like
never mind
i've seen conspiracies where they
probably don't exist my sister loves me
i'm sure she does when we lost her
father she was allowed to come from
russia for the funeral it's not that
hard to understand that in that moment
she was there to help me she put me
through school she got me this job
she saw how agents were dying and she
sacrificed her men to bring me in and
protect me
you don't do that if you don't care
about someone
felix wasn't having a bar of it he
refused to believe that natalia's help
was anything but family helping one
another
she had offered him a role within the
black tusk after seeing how out of depth
the division was
she had saved him and had she not got
him out of that situation quickly it
would have certainly meant that he could
have died
you ready for this absolutely you don't
mind not knowing who the target is i
trust faye
and frankly she's right
we've had too many leaks
she's smart to keep this one close to
the vest do you know who the target is
i've got my suspicions but i'm not going
to speculate i think it's kelso okay
sparky don't strain that big brain of
yours
being young and eager felix is keen to
get started on the op but expresses
confusion around the lack of intel
but viper trusts fae and understands the
reason behind the secrecy
unwilling to rock the boat felix accepts
this and continues with his preparation
when instructed to do so he sets forth
executing his part of the operation
however this would ultimately lead to
the division getting involved
and they would quickly hunt him down
and eliminate him
so what did natalia have to prove to her
father
the circumstances around his death seem
very suspicious
on one hand maybe natalia's american
stepmother did murder him
or maybe it was natalia who took him
down successfully framing it on his wife
being somewhat separated from her
father's new family and not having the
tight connection that they may have once
had she might have been presented with
an opportunity that required her to step
up and take control
perhaps she was approached by someone
from the inside of the us government
before assembling the black tusk and
before she could act on anything she
would need to remove the one small
obstacle in her path her boss
and father
alexei sokolov
perhaps he had always been skeptical of
her abilities to take over his company
and plan to appoint felix as a successor
and this could be why she sees felix as
a threat
if he chose to do so he could have a
larger claim to the family business and
fortune than herself and her new empire
was not something she was willing to
share or lose to a younger half-brother
in my opinion she had absolutely no
emotional bonds to him
felix was a smart kid but he was young
and naive
he was proud of finally being a part of
his sister's life and she knew this
felix was so smitten by natalya's
presence her immense generosity plus the
chance to reunite their family that he
immediately shut down potential warning
signs that could point to anything
sinister to do with his sister
the other interesting pieces that have
come from alice's memoirs was an
individual called mcmanus and something
named the button
in regards to mcmanus we find out more
about this individual in another piece
of intel that we collect later on i'll
be covering this more in another video
but what i will say for now is that
we've been speculating for a long time
over who this group with ties to the us
government is the ones behind the black
tusk the ones who are potentially
responsible in some part for what
amherst did right at the beginning of
this pandemic
while we know that natalya is the owner
of the black tusk there is someone or a
group that is much bigger than her who
is calling the shots
mcmanus is this person or at least a
part of this group
but what about this thing called the
button that natalia and alice are so
worried about
there are a few comments in the memoirs
that led us towards one potential
direction
where ellis said do what she says push
the button and blow up the world that
she is trying to build an empire on the
ashes and that they can't activate the
protocol without his permission that
there are fail-safes against it
this all leads us to believe that he's
talking about the use of nuclear weapons
the president has a sole authority to
use nuclear weapons
some advisers may try to change the
president's mind or resign in protest
but ultimately the pentagon must comply
with the commander-in-chief's order
the senior officer in the pentagon war
room must formally authenticate that the
person ordering the strike is indeed the
president
the submarine and intercontinental
ballistic missile crews then receive the
message within seconds
the weapons are kept in submarines and
80 foot deep missile silos across the us
others are stored at air bases where
they can be loaded on long-range bombers
the nuclear football a black leather
briefcase contains the authentication
codes
these can't simply be taken and used by
someone else
there are too many checks in the system
to ensure that the order came from the
president himself
if this is indeed what they are trying
to do launch nuclear weapons this tells
us a couple of things that we had no
confirmation on up until now
one the military is still active at
least in some sort of capacity which
makes sense the locations where nuclear
weapons are stored are generally pretty
remote particularly in the cases of
underground silos and submarines
and secondly there is some sort of
government structure still in place
perhaps the black task doesn't have
quite as much control as we thought
but why would they want to launch
nuclear missiles
in all of history only two nuclear bombs
have been set off during wartime and
that was against a country that couldn't
retaliate with its own
these days countries only have them to
use as a deterrent to other countries
who also have them it is in no one's
best interest to fire them
not only with the country being fired on
be sending some right back but the
devastation would result in a nuclear
winter where massive quantities of soot
and smoke would remain in the atmosphere
for years blocking direct sunlight from
reaching the surface causing a
planet-wide drop in temperature leading
to widespread crop failure and famine
across the globe
plus we need to remember that russia you
know because it's always about russia in
the united states is looking to be in a
better position through this whole
pandemic
the us is still one of the most hard-hit
countries in the world
[Music]
or perhaps assuming the most obvious
thing isn't necessarily what this button
is referring to
we need to remember that the division
only answers to the president so maybe
this is referring to something along
those lines
it could be that he holds the power to
change the status of all agents to rogue
so they will no longer have the support
of the jtf and settlements will start
treating them differently
or maybe it's something to do with isaac
and shutting it down effectively killing
the communications network
regardless alice is now dead
so i guess some of these concerns have
been removed
but who is next in line for succession
is there another president that has been
sworn in
do the black task have access to this
person
i feel like this video has been a bit of
a mishmash of random information
speculation and a bit of a story recap
based on the new intel that has come our
way
the hardest part for me with these is to
stay on track as there are so many
different angles you could speculate on
further
these are the sort of videos that i
often don't end up releasing because
they're more of an ever so slightly
controlled brain explosion with no clear
answer that often leads to more
questions
but a lot of you told me you like these
so here it is
thank you for watching and running
through the journey with me with the
other fellow comms that i still haven't
talked about you're likely to see a few
more of these going forward
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh